pas toujours facile de faire des choix
judicieux en épicerie
l'individu vit dans un environnement et
présentement l'environnement au Canada
l'environnement alimentaire il nous
encourage à faire des choix d'aliments
malsains donc on a besoin d'aider les
consommateurs avec des outils pour
qu'ils puissent faire des choix plus
éclairés
pour l'information nutritionnelle sur
l'emballage de leur produit et pour
plusieurs personnes ce tableau de la
valeur nutritive est un réel casse-tête
d'autant qu'on prend rarement le temps
de faire des calculs dans les rangées
d'épicerie
l'étiquetage c'est une des stratégies
que l'on peut utiliser pour aider les
consommateurs présentement il y a un
manque de cohérence parce qu'on a un
guide alimentaire canadien qui est en
vigueur depuis 2019 mais on n'a pas
l'étiquetage qui accompagne ce guide-là
en 2018 Santé Canada proposait un
nouveau règlement pour contraindre les
fabricants à ajouter un pictogramme bien
visible sur les aliments emballés nous
proposons aujourd'hui l'affichage d'un
symbole nutritionnel en forme de loupe
cet avertissement sera obligatoire sur
les aliments qui dépassent de 15% la
valeur quotidienne recommandée en gras
saturés en sucre ou en sodium les
composantes les plus susceptibles
d'augmenter les risques pour la santé
ce pictogramme devait apparaître en
décembre 2022 et voilà que Santé Canada
a annoncé qu'elle reporte cette
obligation à 2026
soit près de 8 ans après le dépôt du
nouveau règlement
j'étais très déçu pas très surpris mais
ça confirme pour moi que le santé Canada
a fait un compromis et sert davantage
des intérêts privés que l'intérêt public
parce que ce repas là n'est pas
l'avantage des Canadiens on est rendu où
est-ce que on doit penser que Santé
Canada et est un une institution
négligeante qui va être tenu responsable
dans les prochaines années vraiment
d'avoir causé davantage de maladies
chroniques on croule sous les maladies
chroniques en diabète obésité
hypertension tout ça est relié en fait
au phénomène de leur bon point de
l'obésité c'est plus d'un Canadien sur
deux donc on est face à une épidémie
négligée négligée par Santé Canada ça
fait 8 ans ça au total la si on compte
de 2018 à 2026 c'est 8 années où est-ce
que on sait que ça rend les gens malades
ce nouvel étiquetage on a annoncé un peu
plutôt cet été que ça allait être poussé
à 2026 comment ça s'explique
on proposait une période de transition
de 4 ans parce que faut donner
suffisamment de temps à l'industrie de
samedi avec le règlement qui est une des
premières approches mais aussi après
pouvoir utiliser leur stop notre monde
commentaire on a dû passer à travers
toutes ces commentaires là et faire
certains ajustements quand il était
justifiés donc si je comprends bien
c'est un peu l'industrie qui ralentit le
processus d'implantation de ce nouvel
étiquetage
nous qui demande certains changements il
y a des changements qui sont demandés
par d'autres groupes à l'intérieur de
centre Canada mais aussi par l'Agence
Canadienne et l'inspection des aliments
si on met une période de transition qui
est trop courte ça peut emmener aussi du
gaspillage
Santé Canada inclut ce nouvel étiquetage
dans une vaste stratégie pour une scène
alimentation dont fait notamment partie
le nouveau Guide alimentaire canadien
c'est une portion de 30 g avec 12 g de
sucre donc ça ça serait considéré et lui
ensuite on commence avec en analysant
des céréales populaires l'équipe du
professeur Moubarak a relevé des
incohérences dans l'application du
pictogramme par exemple si l'étiquette
avait lieu aujourd'hui ce produit serait
affiché comme étant trop élevé en sucre
mais pas celui-ci
malgré le fait que le tiers des calories
de ce produit proviennent du sucre
ajouté donc on peut pas dire que ce
produit n'est pas sucré il est très
sucré alors pourquoi 1 est pas l'autre
parce que simplement ce produit à un
gramme de moins que le critère fixé par
Santé Canada dans cette boîte de
céréales il y a pas de sucre il y a pas
de sel ajouté il y a seulement des
ingrédients nobles des noix des graines
des fruits secs cependant la quantité de
sucre est assez élevé ce qui fait en
sorte cette boîte serait presque
étiqueté et ça nous montre très bien que
on encourage pas l'industrie a changé la
recette donc il y a pas de hiérarchie
entre un sucre ultra transformé et des
canneberges exactement donc une personne
pourrait penser que ce produit se
produit ont la même qualité alors que
celui-ci est à déconseiller les experts
que nous avons consultés déplore le
retard d'implantation de la loupe et
certains sont d'avis que cet outil n'est
pas le meilleur que l'organisme aurait
pu choisir
plusieurs nutritionnistes dans le monde
cite le nutri-score français en exemple
un indicateur qui guide les
consommateurs dans leur choix selon la
valeur nutritive des produits
contrairement à la loupe canadienne qui
elle cible simplement ceux qui excèdent
un certain taux de sodium de sucre ou de
gras par exemple ici on a des pois
chiches le nutriscor indique feu vert et
a c'est à dire un aliment très bien côté
qu'il faudrait privilégier par contre
celui-ci indique feu rouge et eux la
pire note sans surprise d'un aliment à
éviter ou à manger occasionnellement on
Europe on a choisi plutôt à la fois
d'avertir sur des produits qui sont pas
de bonne qualité nutritionnelle et de
promouvoir des produits de bonne qualité
nutritionnelle
Serge ergberg médecin nutritionniste en
France a été l'un des architectes du
nutri-score son équipe a mis plusieurs
années pour instaurer ce système
volontaire bravant de constante pression
de l'industrie il a même reçu des
menaces de mort c'est une simple
information qui donne une consommateur
mais c'est tout de même un droit qui
doit lui être fourni d'avoir accès à une
information simple
compréhensible par tous et qui lui
permettent vraiment d'intégrer la
dimension santé dans ses choix
alimentaires pour moi ça demeure le
nutri-score qui est l'outil le plus
réaliste parce que bon quand on parle de
pourcentage un pourcentage là c'est pas
tout le monde qui est capable de
comprendre ça quand on arrive avec des
couleurs passer beaucoup plus parlant
pour quelqu'un
même s'il a fait ses preuves dans sept
pays européens le nutriscore suscite
encore de l'opposition chez les
industriels les lobbys sont extrêmement
actifs pour essayer de retarder sa mise
en place voir réussir à bloquer tout un
tas de stratégies pour empêcher la mise
en place de cette mesure qui pourtant
considérée comme efficace
scientifiquement mais qui vient heurter
un certain nombre d'intérêts économiques
on ne se soucie pas de toutes les
implications que ça peut avoir en terme
de maladies chroniques on a plus
d'argent pour soigner tout le monde donc
qu'est-ce qu'on attend qu'est-ce qu'on
attend pour changer les choses donc
entre temps je pense que le message est
très clair pour les Canadiens que on
doit se débrouiller par nous-mêmes et je
pense que développer l'autonomie
former l'esprit des gens et la solution
dans un monde où les politiques ne
semblent pas être développés pour le
bien-être des citoyens mais plutôt pour
défendre les intérêts du secteur privé
[Musique]